ils scrutent le ciel et son téléphone et
jérôme regnault suite deux à trois fois
par jour l'évolution de la météo c'est
la terre est plus dur là en effet on va
se poser la question de sortir les
charrues pour ce céréalier c'est demain
que les conséquences de la sécheresse
estivales vont se faire sentir
l'exploitation arrive en période de
labour de préparation des terres pour
les semis l'an passé on était dans des
conditions encore plus difficiles où la
savait vraiment impacté les levées de
colza là on est encore tôt dans la
saison donc il est encore temps que la
pluie arrive et que les potentiels soit
soit là elle les orages du début du mois
d'août n'ont pas changé la situation les
yvelines ont été placés en situation
dallaire sécheresse le 23 juillet par la
préfecture
mais tout n'est pas négatif pour cet
agriculteur l'a pas eu trop d'impact sur
les cultures d'automne
et donc sur le résultat de la moisson en
ça a été bon à très bon pour les
céréales c'est à dire et en quantité et
en qualité
les gras été formé au moment où la
sécheresse et est arrivée la canicule de
fin juin ça a été beaucoup plus
ordinaire à catastrophiques sur les
colzas qui eux avaient subi la
sécheresse de l'été 2018
le mail ça va être particulier en effet
puisqu'il a pris lui le coup de chaud au
moment où il aurait dû être au pouvoir
même commencé ses floraisons donc lui le
maïs qui sera récolté entre dans la
région c'est souvent entre mi et fin
octobre
on va jusqu'à fin novembre mais souvent
me à fin octobre lui se porte plutôt mal
jérôme réunion exploitent 300 hectares
de terrains où il cultive principalement
des céréales la pluie est annoncée pour
la fin de semaine avec de rares averses